[Musique]
les tribunaux pourront-ils sauver la
planète
la question peut vous paraître un peu
bizarre quand on pense au tribunaux on
s'imagine plutôt des grands procès à
l'américaine avec les effets de manche
les avocats les objections mais c'est
President ou alors on pense aussi au
divorce long et douloureux ou les
parents s'entrent déchirent pour la
garde de leurs enfants
et pourtant pourtant il se pourrait bien
que les tribunaux jouent enrôles crucial
dans ce qui est probablement la plus
grande crise que l'humanité et jamais eu
à affronter j'aimerais vous raconter
trois histoires d'avocats
premier histoire nous sommes en 2018 en
novembre 2018 Greta Thunberg n'est pas
encore apparu sur la scène
internationale la grève du climat n'est
pas encore née et une joyeuse équipe
d'une grosse dizaine d'activistes s'en
vont à Lausanne jouer une partie de
tennis dans le hall de crédit Suisse
pourquoi une partie de tennis est bien
parce que Roger Federer l'icône Suisse
icône national s'il en est et bien parce
que Roger Federer prête son image il est
l'égérie de crédit Suisse qui est un
très mauvais élève en matière
d'investissement dans les énergies
fossiles et pourquoi une banque pourquoi
Crédit Suisse est bien parce qu'à
l'époque c'était la deuxième banque en
plus d'être une mauvaise élève c'était
la deuxième banque du pays entre-temps
c'est devenu la première honte du pays
mais ça c'est un autre débat deuxième
histoire nous sommes en 2015 2016 et de
nombreuses études documente déjà
que l'augmentation des températures la
hausse des températures sur la planète
les canicules la sécheresse ont des
impacts gravissimes sur la santé
augmentation des troubles respiratoires
problèmes cardiovasculaires et même sur
mortalité chaque année de nombreuses
personnes des milliers de personnes sur
le continent européen meurent uniquement
parce que les températures augmentent
et cette réalité cette grave réalité
touche en particulier les seniors les
plus âgés d'entre nous et en particulier
les femmes les femmes les plus âgées
sont les personnes les plus vulnérables
face à l'augmentation des températures
alors ensuite un groupe de femmes âgées
les aînés pour la protection du climat
décide de ne pas se laisser faire et
s'en prennent à la Confédération en
demandant qu'elle en fait qu'elle en
fasse plus qu'elle s'engage davantage
pour lutter contre le dérèglement
climatique
troisième histoire nous sommes en
novembre 2022
la FIFA organise sa coupe du monde de
foot au Qatar est présente l'événement
comme un événement neutre en carbone la
bonne blague
avec des stades construits au milieu du
désert des stades qu'il faut climatiser
parce qu'il y fait trop chaud
n'y aurait-il vraiment aucun moyen de
leur faire rendre des comptes à ces
petits blagueurs de la FIFA
comment
peut-on en arriver là à quoi ça sert-il
la justice si vous êtes sur l'autoroute
et que vous roulez à 140 km/h alors que
la limite comme tout le monde le sait
est à 120 km/h une autorité est là pour
vous sanctionner pour vous amender dans
les cas les plus graves on peut aller
même jusqu'au tribunal si vous êtes
employé et que votre patron ne vous paye
pas vous pouvez saisir un tribunal pour
réclamer votre due pour faire justice
si vous êtes prisonnier et que l'état
dans lequel vous êtes en prison torture
malmaines maltraite ses prisonniers et
bien vous pouvez saisir la justice pour
faire valoir vos droits humains vos
droits de l'homme jusque devant la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme si
nécessaire
et encore si vous êtes une femme au
tournant des années 1990 dans le
magnifique canton d'Appenzell rode
intérieur vous n'avez pas le droit de
vote parce que la moitié masculine de la
population considère que le droit de
vote des femmes c'est un peu surfait et
confond cette revendication ne mérite
pas d'être suivi alors que faites-vous
vous saisissez la justice et les
tribunaux en réalité le Tribunal fédéral
dit ça suffit maintenant il faut pour
des raisons d'égalité donnée aussi le
droit de vote aux femmes alors comment
tout ceci fonctionne-t-il la justice et
bien sûr pensez par de nombreux
philosophes de nombreux
écrivains de nombreux spécialistes
depuis de longs siècles au début du
16ème siècle on était encore à l'âge du
pouvoir sans partage et le philosophe
Machiavel a pondu un ouvrage qui a
traversé les siècles le prince un
ouvrage dans lequel il donne des
conseils pour rester au pouvoir pour
régner sans partage il semblerait que
certains gouvernements d'aujourd'hui
encore beaucoup d'inspiration à la
lecture de cet ouvrage vous aurez
remarqué que je n'ai pas fait féminisé
le terme gouvernant il semblerait que ce
soit quelque chose qui soit souvent lié
à la testostérone nous avons attendu
deux siècles et puis est venu à ce
moment-là Montesquieu philosophe
écrivain grand philosophe s'il en est
qui lui s'est dit qu'il fallait ajouter
un peu d'équilibre un peu de pouvoir et
surtout de contre-pouvoir pour réduire
les risques d'autoritarisme alors il a
construit sa très célèbre théorie de la
séparation des pouvoirs il y a le
Parlement qui fait les lois qui pose les
règles de vie en société il y a le
gouvernement qui les applique au
quotidien et puis la liste il y a les
tribunaux qui contrôlent tout ceci
comme parlementaire je peux vous dire
que les politiques membres des
parlements membres des gouvernements ont
souvent tendance à oublier l'existence
des tribunaux et comme parlementaire je
peux vous dire aussi à quel point dans
les instances politiques il est
difficile très difficile de faire
progresser la cause du climat alors
justement le climat justement le climat
peut-on faire quelque chose en justice
peut-on aller en justice pour le climat
c'est ça la question que nous allons
nous poser parce que depuis de longues
années de longues décennies
pourraient-on dire le constat est grave
des citoyens des scientifiques tirent la
sonnette d'alarme aujourd'hui nous y
voyons malheureusement clair à l'échelle
de la planète en moyenne la température
c'est déjà réchauffé de plus de 1 degré
par rapport à l'air pré-industriel
et se réchauffement n'est pas uniforme
sur le globe en Suisse sur les 10
dernières années la température en
moyenne se réchauffée de 2,5 degrés
chaque année
qui se souvient que le GIEC ce fameux
groupe d'experts pour l'étude du climat
groupe internationaux d'experts pour
l'étude du climat qui se souvient que ce
groupe a reçu le prix Nobel de la paix
en 2007 il y a de cela plus de 15 ans et
pendant ce laps de temps et c'est assez
rageant de le constater il s'est fait si
peu parfois rien du tout pour lutter
contre ce fléau des énergies fossiles et
du dérèglement climatique alors si l'on
veut aller en justice il faut des règles
de droit pour demander leur contrôle
pour demander à des tribunaux de faire
leur travail y a-t-il des règles de
droits en matière climatique la réponse
est heureusement oui depuis quelques
années il y en a de plus en plus des
règles de plus en plus précises de plus
en plus puissantes l'une d'entre elles
très connue bien sûr c'est l'accord de
Paris signé par les États en 2015 et qui
pose le principe l'objectif phare de
limiter à l'échelle internationale
l'augmentation de la température à 1,5
degré
maximum les états aussi se sont dotés de
règles de plus en plus sévères de plus
en plus strictes qui peuvent être
invoqués devant les tribunaux et donc
s'il y a des règles précisément on peut
aller devant les tribunaux et lorsqu'ils
le font on peut aller jusqu'au tribunaux
suprême où en Europe jusqu'à la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme
alors revenons à nos trois histoires si
vous êtes d'accord
nos joueurs de tennis tout d'abord
Crédit Suisse a été bien mal inspiré
elle a déposé une plainte pénale pour
violation de domicile bien mal inspiré
pourquoi et bien parce que et c'est
précisément ce que recherchait les
activistes ça a donné un écho
international à la cause climatique
qu'il portait
durant le procès de première instance
les réseaux sociaux se sont activés un
tweet posté par un très grand
climatologue à atteint Greta toumberg
elle-même qui a retweeté cet
interpellation jusqu'à Roger Federer
elle a interpellé Roger Federer qui
hasard du calendrier venait d'atterrir
en Australie pour y jouer l'Open
d'Australie et vous vous souvenez
peut-être et il s'agissait de l'année où
les feux de forêt dramatique dévastait
le pays en Australie alors où il était
arrivé là-bas alors Roger Federer s'est
senti obligé probablement ou sincèrement
convaincu qu'il fallait réagir il a
réagi par un communiqué dans lequel il a
répété son admiration pour la cause
climatique et pour les activistes qui la
défendent il a aussi rappelé qu'il
considérait que sa position privilégiée
lui conférait un rôle une responsabilité
de discussion avec ses sponsors alors
soyons
Christ Crédit Suisse n'a pas du jour au
lendemain changer sa pratique il lui est
arrivé quelques autres déboires ensuite
mais le message était suffisamment fort
pour qu'il mérite d'être soutenu et
surtout surtout cela a conduit le
tribunal de première instance a
acquitter les activités parce que a dit
le tribunal de première instance ils
avaient agi dans un état de nécessité
pour protéger un bien plus grand encore
que la protection du domicile de crédit
Suisse ce jugement a fait le tour de la
planète les tribunaux malheureusement
deuxième et en troisième instance ne
l'ont pas vu de la même manière et nous
en sommes maintenant à la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme
l'affaire sera tranchée dans les mois ou
les années à venir deuxième histoire des
aînés pour la protection du climat qui
se sont donc adressés à la Confédération
en lui disant cher Suisse chers
Confédération merci d'en faire plus tu
n'en fais pas assez pour protéger le
climat et pour nous protéger nous autres
femmes âgées des conséquences de
l'augmentation des températures
la Suisse a balayé cette requête du
revers de la main les tribunaux ont été
saisis malheureusement en Suisse aucun
tribunal n'a eu le courage de d'examiner
de s'attaquer à la discussion de fond
que les aînés avaient posé devant elle
les tribunaux ont rejeté les requêtes
pour des pures motifs de procédure des
choses très techniques quand on ne veut
pas discuter du fond c'est toujours très
agréable de pouvoir se retrancher
derrière la forme et cette affaire est
maintenant pendant la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme toujours elle nous
avons eu l'audience devant la grande
chambre 17 juges réunis en mars à la fin
du mois de mars c'est la première
affaire qui a été jamais entendu devant
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
au sujet du lien entre droits de l'homme
et des règlements climatiques il y en a
deux autres qui ont suivi
et nous attendons le verdict de ces
trois affaires dans le courant de
l'automne probablement dans tous les cas
ces jugements seront très spectaculaires
et enfin notre troisième histoire a
connu un premier épilogue tout récent
nous avons en agissant pour plusieurs
organisations environnementales nous
avons saisi des autorités qui
surveillent les pratiques commerciales
en matière de publicité et il y a
quelques jours au début du mois de juin
la commission Suisse pour la loyauté
commerciale a condamné la FIFA pour
greenwashing pour éco blanchiment les
FIFA les petits blaguesurs de la FIFA
les petits blagueurs de la FIFA dont je
parlais il y a un instant ne s'en
tireront donc pas indem ils ont été pris
la main dans le pot de confiture
on estime aujourd'hui qu'il y a environ
2000 procès climatiques dans le monde et
je ne parle pas ici de toutes les
affaires pénales des poursuites qui ont
été engagées contre les activistes plus
ou moins offensifs plus ou moins dans
l'illégalité 2000 procès donc en Europe
bien sûr avec une affaire fondatrice
l'affaire dourgenda la fondation
hurgenda contre les Pays-Bas qui a connu
un premier succès très spectaculaire en
2015 notre affaire à tous en France en
Allemagne dans d'autres pays encore et
sur d'autres continents aux États-Unis
une affaire de jeunes enfants qui ont
attaqué l'état du Montana ou alors en
Asie bien sûr en Afrique en Asie l'un
des cas les plus connus et celui d'un
agriculteur pakistanais qui s'en est
pris à son gouvernement en lui
reprochant de ne pas le protéger
suffisamment en lui faisant porter la
responsabilité de la perte de ces
récoltes il a obtenu gain de cause
c'était aussi au tournant des années
2020 alors bien sûr
à elle toute seule les cours à eux tout
seul les tribunaux ne pourront pas
sauver la planète il faut être réaliste
mais il est certain que ces tribunaux
joueront un rôle décisif à l'avenir en
matière climatique malheureusement la
seule politique qui n'est pas en voie
d'extinction c'est la politique de
l'autruche alors oui les tribunaux ne
seront pas de trop pour aider à sauver
la planète
[Applaudissements]